there's a new report out that Zoomers
whom I love you know I'm very Pro Zoomer
in the battle between Zoomer
conservatism and Boomer conservatism I'm
with the Zoomers they're far more
traditional they're more interested in
virtue and order they're more interested
in substantive Goods I'm I love the
Zoomers so this criticism of the Zoomers
is coming from a place of
love there's a report out that gen Z is
aging differently from
Millennials Millennials look weirdly
young maybe not me because my diet
consists of uh espresso black tea
whiskey and tobacco so I don't maybe I
haven't aged quite as as gracefully but
Millennials are aging really really
gracefully generally they look younger
at our at our respective ages than Gen X
did then the Boomers did and then
Zoomers do why is that experts are
blaming this
on skincare routines and cosmetic
procedures so according to this is a
report from I think the Daily Mail
Millennials look relatively younger
healthier diets better knowledge of
skincare and Improvement in makeup means
those born between 1980 and 1997 appear
more youthful than older Generations did
at the same
age overuse or unnecessary application
of filler and toxins at a young age may
affect the natural facial development
causing younger patients to look older
than they are this is according to
celebrity Cosmetics doctor Rasha
rakshani Madam told this to feale male
which is I don't know some outlet but
it's a it's a pun you get it f m a i l
female I bring up the story at all
because
I it's an unpopular but it's an urgent
take cosmetic
procedures in almost all circumstances
make people look worse and many many
people are getting them a lot of Zoomers
are getting them very very young people
are getting these cosmetic procedures
and they almost always make you look
worse I'm thinking especially of the
increasingly popular lip fillers which a
lot of people are getting look if you've
gotten them I'm not saying it's the end
of the world but cut it out they look
bad they always look bad and especially
Botox Botox
Botox botulinum toxin is the most toxic
naturally occurring substance known to
man it is a mil AR grade biological
weapon and the moment people hear this
they stand they're standing around you
know they see news reporters say
botulinum toxin the most poisonous toxic
substance ever discovered by oh great
can you inject it into my face please so
that I don't look my age that would be
great wouldn't it seems like a pretty
bad
idea don't do it it looks bad even even
the little things oh bachum toxin by the
way for those don't know who is that's
Botox it's just it's the most popular
cosmetic treatment in the world don't
stop
it 24% of Americans have had these
treatments if you've had it okay that's
fine we all make mistakes I've made
plenty of mistakes just cut it out for
your own sake for how you will look cut
it out you don't need it you're very
pretty on your own you're you're and
you're relatively much prettier than you
will be if you have all these
mutilations speaking of toxic
substances there's a lady who is
alleging that McDonald's has changed its
rappers to support the state of Israel
so I was starving so I had to get one
quick sandwich from here and I thought
they gave me the wrong sandwich but
conveniently McDonald's Chang their
packaging wow what does that
resemble yeah what is this this one yeah
what is this new packaging it's the MC
chicken wrapper but why is it blue and
white I Hest see that or not I think you
do know this is in support of Israel
they changed they I mean it was like
that actually since a few months ago
because we ran out the regular ones no I
don't think so this is obviously in
support of Israel no I mean we actually
had that for a while though I was here
two weeks ago and it wasn't like this I
mean we have had though CU we have red
one I I know this is not your fault cuz
you're an employee but I think this is
disgusting for them to do this and I
know you in your heart you know in your
heart that this is clearly what this
rapper is for but I mean I didn't know
that though I'm I'm explaining it to you
it is this is what it's for this is the
color of their flag this is clearly what
they're doing and what they're showing
to people and I think it's disgusting
it's clear you
know just like this morning when I got
out of bed and I stubbed my toe and I
knew it was the Jews I knew it why are
you looking at me like that gay not take
let me go what's this jacket you're
putting on me what are you talking about
these guys I had not seen that clip I
just read about it it it lived up to its
reputation um I don't think I don't call
me call me naive but I I don't think
that the McDonald's chicken sandwich
rapper is a subliminal message to
convince the the goyam to support the
state of Israel I don't I don't look I
don't maybe maybe I just haven't
discovered that that dark corner of the
internet yet where I see The Smoking Gun
but I don't really see it and these
people need
help these people the kind of people who
stubbed their toe in the morning and
blamed the
Jews they're the same kind forget the
juice for a second it's the same kind of
people who stub their toe in the morning
and blame the CIA or the people who stub
their toe in the morning and blame the
Illuminati or the people who stub their
toe in the morning who blame this that
or the other
thing and the problem with it
Andrew claven says this all the time
it's not it's not that bigots are wrong
about the other guy it's that they're
wrong about themselves and they're wrong
about the way that the world works
okay if you search for simplistic
answers to political
problems you're you're one you're going
to be wrong and you're going to think
that you know the chicken sandwich is is
a Jewish conspiracy but two you're going
to seed the whole political
order if if you believe that every issue
in the country is is the CIA or
something not only are you going to look
ridiculous you're not going to fix any
problems because it's not just the CIA
and it's not just the FBI and it's not
just the NSA and it's not just the this
NGO and it's not just this left-wing
Mega donor and it's not just this
political systems are extraordinarily
complex
and to to blame it you know in this case
she's blaming it on the Jews it's not
only sort of unjust but it's just
ridiculous and it paralyzes people it
paralyzes people from actually
addressing any of the problems around
them man what a great clip that was now
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nolles channel do it do it thank you
we'll see you next time